l'association jardins passions partage
basé à guyancourt a innové
d'habitude elle a un stand le week-end
du téléthon mais cette année face aux
mesures sanitaires
les membres ont décidé de préparer des
repas destinés à la vente
trois opérations eu lieu en juillet en
novembre et la dernière ce week-end et
pour préparer la centaine de repas il a
fallu s'organiser
la préparation s'est depuis dix jours on
est allé deux fois à paris dans le xiiie
au quartier asiatique pour fêter nos
produits impôts moins cher qu'ici on n'a
plus beaucoup de choix
on a fait des stockage des produits secs
ici puis après on est allé à des firmes
à présent d'y poster du frais les
légumes de la viande ça omni cette fois
des plats asiatiques entièrement
préparée par l'équipe le pâté de crabes
fait maison
les nouilles sautées fait par mon ami
ali après on a fait la salade de fruits
on acheter des fruits en boîte exotique
on a coupé en plus les ananas des
mangues des fruits de la passion des
kiwis en plus pour compléter
après on a fait j'ai fait des cookies
des cookies aux cacahuètes
au sésame aux agents et ça fonctionne le
menu complet était à 20 euros une façon
de manger un bon repas et de contribuer
à la recherche médicale et en plus c'est
pour une bonne cause puisqu'il ya le
téléthon que derrière et comme les
activités du téléthon cette année en
extérieur c'est un peu l'unité et ben
j'en suis à mon
troisième repas que je fais pour le
téléthon au total avec ces trois
opérations de drive repas et quelques
ventes supplémentaires l'association a
récolté un peu plus de 3000 euros
intégralement reversés au téléthon